there's a difference between you dating
somebody who falls in love with you and
you're making 22 bucks an hour working
at balys and she loves you and she stays
with you there's a difference between
you getting married when you're making
$300,000 a year and then there's a
difference between you marrying somebody
when you're worth half a billion dollars
how do you know the girl that marries
you at the end is with you because she
loves you versus she loves what you
offered them right and is that a sin I
think in an Ideal World I am very
comfortable knowing that other people
are also there in your life to get what
they can out of you I'm very comfortable
with that